this is a production of Cornell
University
to start we'll just sort of walk through
some of the basics behind vegetable
raita trial garden project a little bit
of the background and where you can find
more information find footage for the
special variety trails garden project
you'll go to citizen science and scroll
down a little bit and then here it is if
you click here this will bring it to the
page that have all the information for v
vtg so this project is sort of a
demonstration garden and we've done it
in the past I think for maybe four years
in 2011 to 2014 or so but it's sort of
been on hold so we're really happy to
relaunch the project for 2017 every year
has a different theme think of the
pastures in some companion garden theme
or ideological card games or pollinator
friendly games but this year's theme
we're just doing big yields in small
places so here you can find the design
draft so this spirit there um are
several plantings we have a spring
planting that will go in you know march
to april and here are the nine beds so
each bed is three feet by three feet and
then we'll have a summer planting goes
in and around May some of the events
stay the same throughout the season and
some of them change and then we'll also
have a fall planting but not all of the
beds will be planted in the fall but if
you'd like to plant all of them that is
totally cool and you can do that but
here are just some suggestions so we
have some garlic and some cover crafts
so also
on the website you'll find a timeline so
this will sort of guide you through
month by month everything that should be
done so here we are in December today is
opening day for registration and
registration closes on the very first in
March will be mailing out seeds for that
spring planting so you will receive the
seats by mail and then you can directly
so them early in the spring we'll also
have another webinar in mid-march to
sort of get everyone on the same page
touch base answer any questions and go
forward to the planting season and then
may amazed a big month so we'll have a
plant pickup day at Cornell I'm a fourth
so these are the transplants that will
be started by an organic gardening class
here on campus and then you can pick up
the transplants they'll be at the
tomatoes you know more of the tender
perhaps I'm maybe forth and we'll also
have some educational opportunities on
campus as well we're going to connect
with the Cornell botanical gardens and
for one of their vegetable gardens there
and also toured the dolmen Hill student
farm here on campus so it will be a day
to pick up your plans but also to
connect with other educators and tore
some some relevant gardens then in July
we'll have another webinar another
opportunity to touch base as you are
planting and maintaining and also
harvesting part of this project really
focuses on the vegetable varieties for
gardeners database and I'll talk about
that in a few minutes but this will be
the webinar in July will be a time to
sort of go over the database how do you
use it big questions will be answered at
that point
so I guess I'll just use that as a
springboard to show you the database so
this is the vegetable varieties for
gardeners database and it's a really
excellent resource um I think it's used
nationally is it used internationally at
all it is yeah so it's pretty cool so
say you you know pardon if the guy New
York for a beer today and you're really
curious about what tomatoes do well in
your area well you can go on in this
database and see what have what what
varieties have done well for others and
it's similar climate um you just create
an account it doesn't cost anything you
don't get any spam emails or any day is
really simple um and you'll be able to
read a little bit about the variety um
you know about the plant type and you
know how prafulla fruitful it is and you
can maybe discover if it would be a good
fit for what you're looking for when
this gives you an idea of what this
databases I look out so you can see I
mean people are coming from all over the
country it's pretty neat so now I'd like
to talk a little bit about
responsibilities so if you do want to
participate in this project um I'll tell
you first everything that that we do on
our end and then tell you everything
that you would do on your end so we
provide seeds and plants for the spring
and summer plantings um we provide you
the design plan which is right up here
um we provide you with signage so each
of these beds would get their own sign
for visitors to read and I learn a
little bit about what's going there we
provide you that timeline and checklist
which I showed you um and then we also
provide you a template for your local
plan of work including evaluation
templates and lorries going to talk a
little bit about that from the end of
the webinar and then we
support and guidance throughout the
growing season so if you have any
questions or concerns we're happy to
help you out we do have two other
webinars scheduled so those will be
great times to touch base as well and
then sort of your end with the
responsibility so you plant maintain and
harvest the vegetable variety trial
gardens you'll enter data into that
database that I just showed you you will
share progress and photos throughout the
season we'd love to see how things are
doing and just hear about the different
varieties maybe some are doing better
than others maybe some counties are
having different experiences we just
love to hear about it and then you'll
also complete an evaluation at the end
of the season and so this helps us know
any1 1l and what we could do differently
for next year so here you'll see there's
the design the and then the timeline and
the registration form so what kind of
David do you need to collect well Fiona
said it would be great for us to get
just general updates that would be just
anecdotal data but what data we really
want what's one of the varieties that we
have planned yeah um black seeded sixth
and lettuce okay so we would put in the
finder um Simpson I think that will work
and then do search and then his black
seeded since and lettuce alright so you
if you choose to grow black seed Simpson
lettuce what we want / encourage you to
do and ins to register your garden as on
this site so you might choose a name you
know if you're not registered as an
individual I would register you as a as
a county organization so you would go
under blog and sorry I should've ugh it
in first I forgot you might not be
registered so you might go under log in
and you say not registered with our site
you would add a garden profile I
wouldn't call that garden use some name
um that recognizes your Cornell
Cooperative Extension site as the name
and it's little an individual might do
it differently if they're doing it at
home and then you fill this out so you
do need to register if you're not
registered and then you would go back to
that lacks of once you're registered um
you can um then you can add a review I'm
logged in now and so once you're
registered get this blog and successful
this is what we're expecting you each
each demo site to share so just a
general review that would just be
verbally what you thought of what
happened and then you provide overall
rating and maybe you can run the mouse
over that drop-down menu and you
basically give it 125 start on overall
rating taste yield ease reliability and
that's just you know how easy was it and
unyielding taste is obvious and it's
kind of personal so you might have to
take a consensus and then if you want to
upload a picture you can upload a
picture I think that's works this is
like a interface that we developed a
long time ago and it functions usually
but uh and we think the load picture
still works but let us know if it
doesn't and then you just save it and I
will save my excited right anything so
that's that's what we're expecting for
that and though can you participate only
part of the programming yes you can so
if you feel that the spring planting is
something that you're super interested
in but maybe you don't have the capacity
or the volunteers to do it like a summer
in the fall that's totally fine um you
can also substitute plant say oh man I
really don't like microgreens our
volunteers feel like my grades we don't
know how we would use these so you can
do a different planting in that bag you
would have to just adjust the signage
template yeah so if you do do the
partial season planting you would have
to provide your own seeds and
transplants so if you do the full one
you get to see to the transplant sweet
if you just do partial
planting you get you have to provide
them is that clear so what we're doing
is incentivizing people who do the whole
thing get the plants from seeds if we
have extras we will share those with
people from doing partials and we've
still even if you're doing partials
please register because um we might be
able to accommodate that but we're
giving priority to people are doing the
full thing with our budget and if we
don't have a budget all spent on those
people who are doing the full thing we
might be able to accommodate partial
it's in place but they're not the same
size um you can still that's okay so we
just give this design based on this 3 by
3 bed if you have bigger beds you know
you wouldn't have to think through your
own adjustment of how many plants so you
can still do it but you'll have to think
through those adjustments or you know
consult with us and we certainly help
with that and where can i interject is
really plan so if you are starting from
scratch and you don't already have the
garden beds established we have a
document that will help you sort of walk
through the process so this is on the
website recommended site prep so walk me
through the soil to lay out building the
bags what materials are best fencing
signage and there's even a video on our
website that you can watch this just
three minutes and it shows how one of
these gardens sites was established
before and then another question was
will this only be for 2017 no we have
been trying to do this I think since 20
but what was that year 2012 yeah we've
been doing been trying to do this
special varieties trial project for the
last five years so we're very thankful
that fiona is is taking the lead ins
developed all this support network for
it so that's why we're launching yet
full on this year and our plan is to do
it every year so come up with a
different design in future years or
maybe because they're all annuals we can
modify the design
based on your on how it goes for you and
the feedback you provide maybe you would
even throw out suggestions on what you'd
like to see is part of the plantain and
2080 so the hope is that this is on
going into the future all right let me
just show you one more thing it's not
asking questions I love this project so
under garden guidance we do have that
pollinator friendly thing under garden
guidance we have food gardening and
growing vegetables we have this selected
list of Edgehill varieties / gardeners
in New York State and so again this is
for 2017 we create this every year and
so there's some varieties you want to
get some of those varieties off this
list but some of them aren't on this
list so the other thing that you'll be
helping us do is if you put the data
into the federal varieties for partners
website that helps inform this document
if if the stuff is good right the only
what's the recommended stuff in here but
you can see one of sorry this is got a
mouse out of control so some of the
varieties on this list that have this
asterisk on them they came from
recommendations from New Yorkers from
the vegetable variety list so that's
ultimately where we're going we want to
repeat this many years and we want New
York State gardeners and our
associations you're doing vegetables
trial gardens to be informing this
document that's the overarching of a
long-term goal is that gardeners are the
ones who who help help us come up with
this list um question comes in do you
have suggestions on how to break up the
maintenance work among volunteers oh oh
wait I got an answer from Laura in wayne
county in wayne county we assigned each
interested volunteer a bed
an avid signage this bed is maintained
by Mars Master Gardener volunteer and
their name there's some accountability
it maybe it's a couple names and so the
bed is only three by three and um and so
that's that that was on there we go we
did this beautiful bed mmm and anybody
else have any suggestions I like that
one I think every county is so different
and you know their volunteer force and
the time that their educators have to
maintain this so it might be a little
bit different for everybody but if you
have done this project in the past and
you've found that your way of
maintenance works really well please
share another strategy that I've heard
is so there's always a time in the
garden and here each week when there's
an educational opportunity but while
you're doing the education you might do
a little maintenance at that same time
so other resources on this page yeah I
didn't dive into those okay what we also
wanted to share with you is some tools
to help you a report your annual
reporting as we always do and also
measure your success so we have an
evaluation some sample evaluation forms
and they open up in words so I think I
got it down they'll download if I click
on them and then so these are just some
sample questions I guess I'll open it up
it's going to be okay it will open up in
word and I think I have to scoot over to
word are you showing the screen desktop
so they should be able to see it okay
good so it's opening up hopefully y'all
can start to see the word document open
up so you can see she has a simple
evaluation form that you might have ever
you have an event or some other that
maintenance learning time you can use
this form and then we also we have
other form of the other evaluation form
is more open-ended questions the other
thing i want to share is some about your
plan or your local plan of work so some
of you educate errs might think that
this looks familiar because you've had
to fill out a local plan of work so you
might choose your food gardening and the
special friday trial garden to meet one
of these outcomes which is part of our
whole plan of work and so she really
just put this document here with the
thought that you would pick the you
would delete the things that weren't
relevant to what your focus was and then
you would keep the others and so um that
was a little background and so she she's
kind of filled this in for you um so it
would be easy for you to do your program
planning paperwork that you all have to
do you can sort of choose she made in
different colors so you can sort of
choose your theme and then work through
the whole thing that way with the hope
that this really leads into writing a
very easy success story once you've
collected some information too so she
added that tool right to that website so
if you go to the staff webpage under
units organizational development program
planning and development I just want to
point out some changes and state by plan
of work that impacts our Master Gardener
volunteer program so that local plan
work template here it is right here you
that that's the one she filled in but
you can get it on that staff website
there's the statewide plan work from
which Fiona drew those outcomes from and
I just want to point out how it has
changed in the realm of the Master
Gardener volunteer program and there are
six parts than the plan of work and
sorry I'm going to scroll electro rather
fast all going to the last number 61
because that is community economic
vitality examples of statewide regional
initiatives at all within this plan
work include the Master Gardener
volunteer program land use in public
spaces you know we might be doing some
work related to land use in public
spaces with a restauranteur volunteer
program and this is a brand-new point in
the plan of work it was worded
differently previously it was not called
land use in residential spaces before
and and you can see here the number of
residents practicing management tactics
and home lawns and gardens and
landscapes that support environmental
stewardship and a sustainable community
so I think the bulk of our support of
our community falls in this area for
Master Gardener volunteer program and
there are some footnotes here because
you might be doing something a little
more specific and that you might want to
affiliate with a different outcome in
the plan of work and so I wrote those
out here if you're doing something
focuses on climate change adaption and
mitigation Water Resources biodiversity
natural resource protection you go back
up this whole document scroll back up to
the second portion of the plan of work
under climate change there's a check out
2.1 2.4 and 2.7 there that's really a
bank codes by i think i want includes
biodiversity and then in 3.7 in the
natural resource the environment and
natural resource one also covers those
sorts of things if that's a thrust of
your program and your head or in the
future if by chance you're focusing on
compost waste management if you look at
the third part of the plan Environment
and Natural Resources sustainable energy
3.6 and 3.7 deal with composting and
waste management and then if you're
focusing on school community home and
food gardening you would refer to the
plan of work of nutrition food safety
and security and obesity and prevention
4.4 talks about food security one
there's some background and Fiona pulled
some of that back
into that plan of work they've already
spelled out for you here so this usually
it also includes activities include the
Master Gardener volunteer program seeks
supper program youth grow is also
affiliated with us so that might be one
of the things that you're the thrust of
your program is to to see changes in the
number of people growing their own food
well thanks everybody and look for you
reach out with questions we're happy to
continue this conversation this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell.edu